Donald Trump yesterday had one of the most
concerning and outrageous days on Twitter,
maybe of his entire presidency.
And in the past when we've talked about Trump's
crazy Twitter days, it's often the number
of times that he's tweeting, sometimes a hundred
times dozens and dozens of tweets and retweets.
But yesterday was not crazy in terms of the
number of tweets, but it was crazy because
of the content of the tweets, including very
strange tweets about Iran as well as re tweeting
an image of Nancy Pelosi in Muslim dress in
front of an Iranian flag.
And the world continues to laugh at us day
in and day out because this madman is our
president and the proportions of this have
expanded beyond even absurdity into something
reminiscent of an unbelievable alternate universe.
Let's take a look at the completely erratic
bipolar nature of these tweets.
I'm using bipolar, not in the medical sense.
Simply relating to extremes of different kinds.
Donald Trump starting with to the leaders
of Iran, do not kill your protesters.
Thousands have already been killed or in prison
by you and the world is watching.
More importantly, the USA is watching.
Turn your internet back on and let reporters
roam free.
Stop the killing of your greater rainy and
people generally speaking a good sentiment
but couched with a sort of strange threat
in it.
Then going into many Mike Bloomberg is spending
a lot of money on false advertising.
I was the person who saved preexisting conditions
in your healthcare.
You have it now seemingly taking credit for
Obamacare, which of course he is criticized
and has nothing to do with while at the same
time winning the fight to rid you of the expensive,
unfair and very unpopular individual mandate,
which is the only thing holding Obamacare
together going on to say, and if Republicans
win in court and take back the house of representatives,
your hell healthcare that I have now brought
to the best place in many years will become
the best ever by far.
I will always protect your preexisting conditions
and the Democrats will not, of course, a complete
and total lie.
Then Donald Trump retweeting some anti Nancy
Polosi stuff.
Then retweeting a picture of Chuck Schumer
wearing a turban and Nancy Pelosi wearing
Muslim dress.
Of course, a doctored image, not a real one.
I assume.
I don't have to tell most people in the audience
that.
And then after all this, it really got crazy
with a multi tweet screed where Trump says,
Bernie Sanders volunteers, misspelling Bernie's
name are trashing Elizabeth Pocahontas, Warren
misspelling, Pocahontas.
Everybody knows her campaign is dead and want
her potential voters.
Many B is also trying but getting tiny crowds,
which are all leaving fast.
Elizabeth is very angry at Bernie.
Do I see a feud brewing going on to say the
Democrats and the fake news are trying to
make terrorists Soleimani into a wonderful
guy?
Completely untrue.
Only because I did what should have been done
for 20 years.
Anything I do, whether it's the economy, military,
or anything else, will be scorned by the raffle,
left a do nothing Democrats.
Then he praised, uh, Iranian protesters and
went into calling for impeachment to simply
end.
Or I guess he means be canceled saying, why
should I have the stigma of impeachment attached
to my name when I did nothing wrong?
Read the transcripts.
He's not released them.
A totally partisan hoax never happened before.
House Republicans voted one 95 to zero with
three Dems voting with the Republicans.
Very unfair to tens of millions of voters,
almost as unfair as the senators representing
just 7% of the population getting to equip
Donald Trump.
As I spoke about before, Trump continuing
many believe that by the Senate, giving credence
to a trial based on no evidence, no crime,
read the transcripts, no pressure impeachment
hoax rather than an outright dismissal.
It gives the partisan Democrat witchhunt credibility
that it otherwise does not have.
I agree, seemingly suggesting that it should
all just be counseled and going on and on
and on, including Donald Trump, appearing
to tweet a picture of a dead body during this
wild uncontrolled string of images and posts
a bloody male figure draped over a barbed
wire fence being tweeted by Donald Trump.
My hope is that after we removed Donald Trump
in November, of course, still is the top priority
that these tweets do become part of the historical
record.
So that we all remember the true nature of
living through this era where you have this
additional constant, uh, whacked out narrative
happening on Twitter by Donald Trump.
We've learned money cannot buy you class.
The Donald Trump family is exhibit a in that
realization.
But beyond that, we need this as part of the
historical record because we need to never
forget that Republican senators effectively
stood by and allowed this to continue.
20 of them could end this insanity with a
single vote and they're not going to do it.
And we can't allow history to be written in
a way where that is anything short but a completely
disgusting and irresponsible action by Republicans
in the house and Senate.